alors je pense que oui les retraités
notamment dans les professions de
restauration du spectacle et s'est fait
toutes les professions impacté par
pleinement par la crise yani terre le
confinement ça va être très compliqué
pour eux en revanche les autres
retraités je ne sais pas moi je fais
partie du secteur public donc j'avouerai
que cela ne me concerne pas ma retraite
je pense sera un peu tranquille en tout
cas un peu plus sécurisé pour ces
personnes-là donc mais oui effectivement
je suis assez inquiète pour ces
catégories de professionnels
honnêtement je suis pas inquiète parce
que j'avais la chance de travailler dans
une bonne entreprise qui était total et
donc on est très très bien assister
les retraites sans nous
normal change pas il évolue très
progressivement mais
je me trouve plutôt avantagé voilà donc
je suis pas vraiment inquiète mais c'est
un peu égoïste comme situation
en ce qui me concerne je suis pas
inquiète en ce qui concerne les autres
personnes bien sûr c'est plus inquiétant
mais je connais pas toujours la
situation des autres non pas du tout il
ya autre chose à gérer avant en fait
même si la réforme des retraites en vrai
c'était juste un cache cache et qu'ils
nous cachent beaucoup trop de choses
bref
la retraite on en sait déjà qu'on en a
déjà pas
voilà retraite ça vient après quoi oui
moi je suis très inquiet parce que déjà
je suis gilet jaune et en tant que
gilles et je pense qu'avec ce avec le
virus qui se passe c'est que le
gouvernement va toujours passé et sous
la table personne ne verra rien puisque
tout le monde est confronté au co vite
on pense au confinement déconfinement on
pense à ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire
le couvre-feu tout ça c'est à dire que
par rapport aux retraites
il en parle plus une fois on est tous
inquiets ou 5es journées tous inquiets
donc voilà on désespère on désespère pas
ce que et
on reviendra pas arrivé à 2022 aux
prochaines élections 2022 on va pas
clôturer la discussion des retraits hors
options de retraite arrivée aux
élections 2022 de macron et
donc magron voilà il peut gagner de ce
côté là moi ce qui me dérange le plus ça
serait qu'on remette en cause la double
la durée de la deûle à la commande la
longueur de la commande la durée de
cotisation et recueillait je pense
notamment aux personnes qui sont qui ont
commencé très tôt voudrais pas qu'ils
soient pénalisés qu'elle soit obligée
d'aller saison commencée à 17 au 18 ans
qu'elle soit obligée d'aller jusqu'à 65
ans ça me gênerait beaucoup con con
bon on met de la le départ à la retraite
automatiquement à 65 ans pour tout le
monde
voilà c'est surtout ça qui me
dérangerait